hey guys real quick there's something
very cool going on at polaris right now
there's a couple videos that they
uploaded that you can find right here
that are part of the special four
players project that they got going on
they asked me to promote this and at
first i was like no no check it out wow
that's awesome and literally you'll do
the exact same thing just exact same as
me because these videos are actually
freaking amazing for what they are and
what they are free videos on the
internet not joking not lying not
hyperbole these videos are pure and
simple awesome so check them out for
yourselves i'm not gonna spoil anything
for you because literally it's
awesome so go check it out until you do
i'm just gonna be here and dance
so
you